la fumée des feux de forêt sera plus
présente jeudi et vendredi dans le sud
du Québec
en plus ils sont poussés vers le sol ce
qui nous donne des concentrations
élevées pour le K-Way aux trois Gatineau
en général les particules se déplaceront
ensuite vers la région de Montréal
amélioration de la qualité de l'air
vers samedi dimanche ce week-end la
santé publique conseille à la population
d'éviter de s'exposer à la fumée ou de
porter un masque m95 une bonne idée
selon ce pneumologue
sont peu efficaces pour filtrer les
particules un masque m95 ou Kane 95 qui
est bien ajusté est en mesure de filtrer
ça et ça peut diminuer de façon
significative ce qui va arriver au
niveau de la respiration les entreprises
on les employés travaillent à
l'extérieur peuvent se procurer
gratuitement des masques N95 dans
plusieurs établissements de santé une
mesure en place depuis une dizaine de
jours c'est aux employeurs qui que leur
travailleur sont exposés à des
particules fines ou des fumées ou qui
sont incommodés par la fumée de fournir
les protections respiratoires le
syndicat de la construction encourage
les employeurs à réorganiser le travail
en cas de mauvaise qualité de l'air il
faut comprendre que nos travailleurs ils
font du travail physique travailler
pendant une période de huit heures ou
plus avec une protection respiratoire ça
peut aussi engendrer d'autres problèmes
les établissements de santé distribuent
aussi des masques m95 aux organismes
vrant auprès des sans-abris mais la
distribution n'inclut pas les personnes
âgées pourquoi ne pas offrir aux gens
qui ont des difficultés respiratoires
des masques m95 tant que les feux de
forêt demeuront aussi intenses les
épisodes de smog risque de rester un
enjeu ici Marie-Claude Morin
Radio-Canada Montréal